san francisco hat es besonders getroffen
und eren beckmann war einer der ersten
als er noch gar nicht wusste dass sich
das affen pockenvirus unter schwulen
gerade besonders ausbreitete nach
wochenlanger quarantäne kann er endlich
wieder raus aber er bleibt vorsichtig
hat angefangen rollstuhl zu laufen alles
ist jetzt ausgerichtet auf die viren
corona und affen brocken
ich suche nach aktivitäten wo ich zwar
in der nähe von menschen bünder kontakt
aber nicht eng ist und ich nicht in
einem kleinen raum mit ihnen
deshalb komme ich gerne hier zum golden
gate park hier sind überall menschen ja
das ist schön nach einem monat in
isolation
er saß fest in seiner kleinen wohnung
und nicht nur das er hatte schier
unerträgliche schmerzen im kopf der hals
und hohes fieber
es tut einfach weh es ist ein brennender
schmerz bei jeder bewegung
wenn die muskeln sich bewegen und die
haut dann fühlst du ihn
als er die ersten flecken sahnte er was
los war affen brocken ehring versuchte
informationen zu bekommen hilfe er rief
ärzte an kliniken schrieb e mails an
seine krankenversicherung an die
gesundheitsbehörden aber nirgends bekam
er antworten praktisch alle fälle
betrafen homosexuelle männer und genau
deshalb sagt er haben die behörden und
hat die politik nicht reagiert dabei
überträgt sich das virus durch engen
körperkontakt und jeder kann sich
infizieren
sie haben die bedrohung nicht ernst
genommen
wenn in diesem land etwas zuerst bei
schwulen männern auftaucht dann wird das
ignoriert als holen probleme und so war
es auch bei den affen
generell werden wir in diesem land nicht
so gut behandelt
erin hat genug geld er ist
krankenversichert beste voraussetzungen
eigentlich für eine gute versorgung
in new york versucht henry viele denen
zu helfen die schlechter dran sind
schwarze und hispanische amerikaner sind
innerhalb der schwulen community
besonders stark betroffen von affen
pocken und haben so erzählt er noch
größere schwierigkeiten auch nur an
einen impftermin heranzukommen deswegen
versucht der barkeeper und aktivist über
social media termine zu vermitteln
listen weise arbeitet er kontakte ab um
zu helfen
die weiße schwule community hat den link
für impftermine schon verbreitet lange
bevor ihn jemand nicht weiß jemand nicht
binäres oder trans leute bekommen haben
deshalb haben sie die ersten termine
bekommen und alle meine freunde sagten
sie kriegen keine impftermine wir haben
uns gefragt wie das sein kann jeder soll
doch sicher und geschützt sein es gibt
medizinischen rassismus und schwarze
werden oft nicht gut betreut da versuche
ich zu helfen
in san francisco und anderen großstädten
gab es zunächst lange schlangen vor den
im kliniken es war nicht einmal klar wer
einen anspruch auf einen test hat vor
ort wüssten sie nicht was zu tun war die
bürokratie überbordet noch immer gibt es
nicht genug impfdosen und das nachdem
man aus corona lernen wollte
wo sind die impfungen die regierung
hatte 20 millionen dosen im nationalen
krisen vor hat doch als der schließlich
gebraucht wurde war der impfstoff
abgelaufen so könnte die verbreitung
nicht aufgehalten werden
16.000 fälle gibt es inzwischen in den
usa
experten bezeichnen den umgang mit den
affen brocken als stümperhaft
die us-regierung hat eine ganze reihe
vermeidbarer fehler gemacht unter
anderem hat sie millionen von impfdosen
verfallen lassen deshalb ist es jetzt
eine aufholjagd es gibt einen weltweiten
impfstoffmangel und so müssen wir in den
nächsten monaten sehen wie wir mit
dieser einschränkung umgehen können wir
werden versuchen müssen so viele
menschen wie möglich zu impfen bei
sparsamem einsatz des impfstoffs
nun wird anders geimpft in einer ampulle
ist eigentlich eine impfdosis nun aber
muss sie für fünf leute reichen so hat
es die gesundheitsbehörde empfohlen und
die wertvollen tröpfchen werden in die
haut injiziert und nicht darunter so
soll der impfstoff möglichst effektiv
genutzt werden corona affen pocken polio
dr hotels hält die häufung von
viruserkrankungen nicht für zufall
bemerkte casey stoney 50 argumentiere
dass wir seit 2015 einen langsamen
anstieg von neuen infektionskrankheiten
erleben durch ein zusammenspiel aus
politischer instabilität klimawandel
abholzung städte baum wodurch die
menschen näher heranrücken an den
lebensraum von tieren deshalb ist vieles
daran vorhersehbar und wir werden neue
mechanismen brauchen die wir mit
pandemischen bedrohungen umgehen
herren beckmann hat für sich seine
kleine lösung gefunden erhält einfach
abstand und neue beziehungen sucht er
erstmal nicht mehr
nein das ist mir im moment nicht wichtig
es passiert so viel anderes gerade für
mich war es schon auch ein zeichen dass
das jetzt für uns nicht gerade der fokus
ist und wir uns vielleicht anderen
lebensbereichen widmen
errang hat die krankheit überwunden
jetzt tut nur noch etwas anderes wie
stigmatisierung und diskriminierung